[Musique]
nous avons le plaisir de recevoir
aujourd'hui jean marc jancovici qui est
le fondateur de carbone 4 une entreprise
de conseil spécialisé dans la transition
vers une économie bas carbone et
monsieur jancovici est aussi le
fondateur président de chypre project un
think tank basé à paris lui aussi
focalisé sur l'économie bas carbone
professeur associé à mines paristech
membre du haut conseil pour le climat
plusieurs ouvrages ont été écrits par
jean marc jancovici sur les questions de
transition énergétique changement
climatique et on retrouvera aussi votre
goût de la transmission parfois aussi la
vulgarisation tout en gardant cette
rigueur sur votre site internet
jancovici je rappelle que djokovic qui
est là pour nous parler de toutes les
enjeux de transition ainsi que nous
l'avons débattu et commencer à débattre
depuis hier et je vous le demande de
l'accueillir très chaleureusement
[Applaudissements]
merci s'est donc terminée bon comme
disait l'autre avant de faire un
discours fleuve je serais bref non je
regrette d'être bref en fait parce que
qui dans cette salle bien qu'il n'y ait
pas de lumière est née après 1992 comme
disent les belges voilà donc j'ai le
plaisir de vous annoncer que vous êtes
les générations futures
oh c'est devant ce n'est pas du tout une
blague au moment où la convention climat
a été signé à rio en 1992
pour ceux d'entre vous qui n'ont pas lu
lé la lire la convention climat dit
qu'il faut préserver le niveau des gaz à
effet de serre dans l'atmosphère à un
niveau qui ne présente pas de danger
pour l'homme en considération des
générations présentes et futures donc en
1992 sont les générations futures tout
les gens qui sont pas encore nés donc
tous les gens qui sont nés après 1992
font partie des générations futures
voilà donc vous pouvez avec cette petite
introduction constater que les
générations futures il ya déjà un gros
paquet sur terre c'est pas la peine
d'attendre plus tard pour s'en occuper
alors la raison pour laquelle je suis
dans cette salle la voici
c'est parce que notre planète terre
nonobstant tous les rêves de business
plan et de grandeur que nous pouvons
avoir à une caractéristique c'est
qu'elle est désespérément fini notre
planète terre faisait un diamètre
approximativement égale à 13 milles
kilomètres
il y a dix mille ans elle fait
aujourd'hui un diamètre tout à fait
approximativement égale à 13 me km et
dans deux siècles ou dans un siècle où
la semaine prochaine ou à l'échéance du
business plan que vous demandera votre
banquier elle fera toujours
treize mille kilomètres de diamètre et
alors cette caractéristique tout bête
fait que nous avons aujourd'hui à 8
milliards de bons hommes sur terre un
certain nombre de petits sujets de place
que nous prenons dans cette boîte de
conserve qui ne veut pas augmenter de
taille et il ya deux sujets en
particulier dont je vais vous parler ce
soir qui sont le climat et l'énergie
alors les optimistes dans cette salle
pour se dire que de parler du climat
c'est pas la peine puisque en 2015 à
paris c'est à dire dans cette bonne
ville
monsieur fabius ancien premier ministre
devenu commissaire priseur pour
l'occasion agite un grand coup sûr
marteau vers frappe la table et déclare
l'accord de paris signé dans l'accord de
paris dit que le monde va être sauvé et
donc il n'y a plus lieu de s'en faire en
ce qui concerne le climat
vous savez moi je suis un petit
ingénieur besogneux et le petit
ingénieur besogneux il ya un truc qu'ils
adorent faire quand il a des grands
slogans comme ceux de monsieur jadot
vous allez recevoir ici non pardon je ne
me dis pas des autres eh bien il adore
faire un truc c'est d'aller regarder les
faits alors il ya un fait que on peut
aller regarder qui est en fait tout bête
qui est combien est ce qu'il y a de
dioxyde de carbone dans l'atmosphère
vous avez ici une courbe qui est gradué
depuis l'année de ma naissance ça tombe
bien parce que je suis vachement
narcissique non chez un hasard je trouve
que la syrie que j'ai trouvée et
graduées depuis l'année de ma naissance
et qui vous donne la quantité de co2 que
vous avez dans l'atmosphère je vous
expliquerai après comment ils y arriver
pourquoi il reste longtemps depuis que
je suis née alors vous voyez cette
courbe elle a une tête extrêmement
régulière et si je vous avais masquer
les années j'aurais pu vous demandez à
votre avis quel est le point qui
correspond à l'entrée en vigueur de la
convention climat parce que si la
convention climat sert à quelque chose
le point qui correspond à l'entrée en
vigueur de la convention climat doit
marquer une inflexion dans la manière
dont cette courbe évolué d'accord avec
moi ici
s'il ya une nouvelle à une quelque chose
de neuf à une incidence sur le résultat
de l'expérience
eh bien on doit le voir alors la réponse
est là ici vous avez en 1900 alors pas
en 1992 mais en 1995 dans la bonne ville
de bonn avec comme ministre de
l'environnement à l'époque une dame dont
vous connaissez tous le nom puisqu'il
s'agit d'un gué la merkel la première
édition de la réunion des parties à la
convention climat c'est comme ça que ça
veut dire comme ça veut dire qu'en
mansion à deux partys c'est à dire que
tous les pays de la planète parce que
tous les pays de la planète ont signé la
convention climat qui dit donc il faut
s'occuper du co2 dans l'air et des
générations futures se réunissent à bonn
alors c'est un gros succès puisque la
convention entre en vigueur
quand vous voyez comment a évolué la
quantité de co2 dans l'atmosphère avant
l'entrée en vigueur de la convention
puis après l'entrée en vigueur de la
convention
après vous avez deux ans après le
protocole de kyoto où les pays dits
riches
ce qu'ils vont prendre des engagements
de réduction de leurs émissions will
résultat après vous avez copenhague qui
selon monsieur jadot était un gros échec
groupe pas plus ni un succès ni un échec
que ce qui s'est passé avant ou après et
là vous avez la convention qui s'est
tenu à paris
donc vous voyez que pour le moment ça ne
marque pas une inflexion avec ce qui
s'est passé derrière alors petite
conclusion provisoire ce que je suis en
train de vous raconter le succès ou
l'échec d'une coop dans la presse
n'engage que le ou la journaliste qui a
écrit l'article est absolument personne
d'autre du reste toute votre vie durant
si j'ai un conseil à vous donner
retenez bien ce si ce qui est écrit dans
le journal n'engage jamais que le ou la
journaliste qui a écrit l'article
et personne d'autre
dit autrement c'est à une source
opposable le journal n'est jamais une
source propose à bhl donc le ce que vous
voyez là c'est qu'en fait la coop enfin
où les combats la convention des nations
unies pour le moment n'a pas d'incidence
sur ce qui se passe dans le monde
alors au moment des questions je
pourrais revenir en fait c'est tout à
fait normal quand vous connaissez le
système onusien
c'est pas là que ça se passe voici la
raison pour laquelle la quantité de gaz
à effet de serre augmentent dans le
monde c'est parce que dans l'atmosphère
pardon c'est parce qu'on en est mais de
plus en plus les gaz à effet de serre
dans les gaz à effet de serre ils ont
une définition en physique qui est très
simple ces dégâts ce qui ont la
propriété d'intercepter des infrarouges
terrestre j'ai pas le temps aujourd'hui
de vous faire un cours de physique parce
que je suis trop limité mais le il faut
retenir ce truc tout bête c'est que un
gaz à effet de serre c'est à gaz qui
intercepte les infrarouges terrestre
dans les gaz qui ont cette propriété ya
notamment le co2 est alors des émissions
de co2 nous en rajoutons un cycle
naturel il ya toujours eu un cycle
naturel sur le co2 dans l'atmosphère
ce qu'il ya des plantes qui ont un cycle
du carbone mais nous on en rajoute au
travers de trois processus qui sont de
brûler des plantes anciennes des
fougères qui ont été séquestrés dans la
croûte terrestre s'appelle du charbon
qui est de brûler du pétrole qui sont
des restes de plancton qui ont aussi été
fossilisé dans la croûte terrestre qui
est de brûler du gaz qui sont aussi des
restes de plancton qui ont été fossilisé
dans la croûte terrestre et c3
combustible s'appelle des combustibles
fossiles parce que c'est des faux cils
cd reste de vie ancienne qui ont été
fossilisé dans la croûte terrestre
retenez que le temps caractéristiques de
formation des combustibles fossiles ça
se balade entre
10 et 400 millions d'années donc c'est
parfaitement renouvelable si vous avez
le temps d'attendre 50 millions d'années
si vous êtes un peu plus pressé que
sarah que votre business plan doit
arriver en cash flow positif un peu plus
vite et bien c'est pas du tout
renouvelable et vous pouvez considérer
qu'on en a un stock de départ qui
donnait une fois pour toute et que ça
n'augmentera pas en cours de partie
après il ya d'autres processus qui
conduisent à émettre des gaz à effet de
serre mais qui ne sont plus du co2 il ya
là des forêts à pardon alors la
déforestation c'est encore du co2 du
reste en ce moment vous avez un
processus de déforestation accélérée qui
a lieu dans un pays qui s'appelle
l'australie parce que l' incendie est un
processus de déforestation
j'ai fait un rapide petit calcul
sinistre mais sympathique que je vous
livre ce qui a déjà brûlé en australie a
engendré des émissions de co2
supérieures aux émissions de co2
annuelles de l'australie en régime
normal parce que tout le carbone qu'il
ya dans les forêts qui sont en train de
brûler ça fait du co2 qui se retrouvent
dans l'atmosphère
vous avez du méthane qui est un autre
gaz que le co2 qui est émis avec le
cheptel bovin les rizières et
l'exploitation des hydrocarbures et en
fait quand vous avez d'autres routes de
perlimpinpin alors ce que vous voyez sur
cette courbe qui vous donne les
émissions graphique qui vous donne les
émissions mondiales c'est que là pour le
coup vous ne voyez pas l'incidence de la
convention climat il ya un autre truc
que vous voyez pas c'est l'incidence de
la dématérialisation de l'économie si je
prends n'importe lequel d'entre vous
dans la salle que je vous donne cette
courbe sans les apps 6 en 10 ans
montrent moins ou est ce que l'économie
commence à se dématérialiser c'est un
peu dur de donner la réponse est le
dernier truc que vous ne voyez pas là
dessus non plus c'est l'essort des
renouvelables et la digitalisation de
l'économie qui soit dit en soi disant la
dématérialise dans tout ça vous ne voyez
pas et la raison pour laquelle vous le
voyez pas c'est que tout ça c'est
essentiellement des slogans de numérique
2d matérialise pas l'économie il faut y
mettre une tonne de co2 pour fabriquer
un ordinateur que j'ai souvenez netflix
c'est un aussi gros une aussi grosse
empreinte carbone que lafarge holcim
parce que il faut des serveurs des
ordinateurs un beau diable
énorme bout de la bande passante
d'internet etc et les renouvelables on
va le voir c'est un peu plus tard on en
parle beaucoup plus que dans le journal
que ça n'a d'importance dans la vraie
vie donc le la réalité aujourd'hui c'est
que les émissions augmentent de façon
ininterrompue sans qu'aucun processus
dont on parle dans le journal comme
étant un processus de modération de
cette hausse ne soit une réalité dans la
vraie vie et je vous le redis à chaque
fois que vous aurez le choix entre
croire le journal et croire les faits
vaut mieux croire les faits en général
le résultat est plus sympathique
d'où viennent aujourd'hui les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre si je les
découpe par activité vous avez 20 % de
la totalité des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre dans le monde qui viennent les
seules centrales électriques à charbon
donc l'électricité au charbon c'est 20%
un cinquième de la totalité des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
le monde
inversement les deux tiers du charbon
qu'on extrait sur terre servent à
alimenter une centrale électrique donc
le charbon c'est par essence l'énergie
de l'électricité
après vous avez 6 7% qui viennent des
centrales à gaz très marginalement à
pétrole parce qu'il n'a quasiment plus
rien n'est très très peu mais des
centrales à gaz
ensuite vous avez 6 % qui viennent des
sols cimenterie dans une cimenterie vous
aller chauffer du calcaire carbonate de
calcium vous allez casser en deux l'un
des deux bouts c'est du co2 qui part
dans l'atmosphère et en plus vous avez
de co2 d'énergie de chauffage donc faire
du ciment ça et mes plans de co2 les
émissions directes du reste de
l'industrie donc les chaudières et les
hauts fourneaux du reste de l'industrie
ces allers 11 ou 12% là dedans les
aciéries c'est à nouveau 5 % ce qui veut
dire que de fer de l'acier et de faire
du ciment donc de faire des logements et
des infrastructures c'est un gros 10 %
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
sur terre ensuite vous avez 6 % des
émissions qui sont les chaudières de
bâtiments alors en france s'est
considérablement plus que ça c'est
plutôt 25 parce que nous n'avons pas de
centrale à charbon parce que nous
n'avons pas d'acier et de ciment à la
mer au même niveau que la moyenne
mondiale parce que nos infrastructures
sont déjà construites et c'est donc le
ce morceau là et parce que nous sommes
un pays des moyennes latitudes qui se
chauffent hiver mais dans le monde c'est
simplement 6%
ensuite les transports
c'est 14 15% dans lequel vous avez 6
pour les voitures 4 pour les camions 2
et 2 pour les avions et les bateaux donc
retenu par exemple dès à présent que les
centrales à charbon dans le monde c'est
un plus gros problème pour le climat que
la totalité des moyens de transport dans
le monde
retenez que les seule cimenterie c'est
autant d'émissions que la totalité des
camions dans le monde et je ne me
présente pas sur ce graphique mais le
numérique c'est aujourd'hui 4 % des
émissions mondiales si je mets boutabout
la fabrication des ordinateurs et des
éléments de réseau et leur
fonctionnement 1 4% ça augmente de 10%
par an truc totalement non soutenable
c'est à dire que dès à présent le
numérique c'est déjà équivalent à la
flotte mondiale de camions en termes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
manger c'est 20% des émissions là vous
avez essentiellement des gaz qui sont
hors co2 donc là dedans vous avez de
cheptel bovin
vous avez un milliard et demi de vaches
sur terre vous avez les rizières
c'est la déforestation c'est en gros 10
% l'essentiel de la déforestation dans
le monde ces abats tribu a bâti brûlées
ou coupées la forêt vous la brûliez vous
faites des cultures la place quels que
soient les cultures et enfin il vous
reste des poudres de perlimpinpin
diverses telles que la gestion des
déchets
le traitement de l'eau les fluides
frigorigènes
donc ce que vous voyez dans ce panorama
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
c'est que ces émissions sont très liés à
beaucoup de choses qui aujourd'hui sont
devenus ordinaire autour de nous se
déplacer disposer d'électricité avoir
des processus industriels donc des
objets manufacturés etc et manger
évidemment et on n'a donc pas à faire à
un problème d'environnement qui est un
problème individuel is able qu'on peut
donner un ingénieur en lui disant
démerde-toi avec ce truc là je veux pas
entendre parler du problème et moi je
m'occupe du reste
d'accord c'est un problème qui est
intrinsèquement liée à la totalité de ce
que nous faisons du soir au matin et du
matin au soir je regarde un peu plus
tard alors une des caractéristiques du
principal gaz à effet de serre que nous
mettons aujourd'hui dans l'atmosphère le
co2 c'est que c'est un occident co2 le
dictionnaire est bien fait ce dioxyde de
carbone vos vieux souvenirs de chimie
vous permettent peut-être pour ceux
d'entre vous qui ont vous permettre
peut-être de vous rappeler que les
oxydes à sont des molécules qui sont
chimiquement inerte c'est à dire qu'une
fois que une molécule est sous forme
d'oxydé si venus lui apporter pas de
l'énergie la molécule reste sous forme
d'oxydé indéfiniment par exemple tous
les métaux qui s'oxyde les gisements sur
terre sont sous forme d'oxydé le faire
par exemple se trouve sous forme d'oxydé
de fer pouvaient pas de faire plus
encore pour les oxydes de fer faut
enlever l'oxygène en amenant l'énergie
et bien le co2 étant un oxyde une fois
que vous l'avez mis dans l'atmosphère il
n'a pas de processus déploration
spontanée donc il est très bien là
dedans
cool raoul comme disait l'autre et il
n'y a que deux processus d'épuration de
du co2 de l'atmosphère l'un des deux est
un simple processus d'équilibrage c'est
la dissolution dans l'océan j'en parlais
et l'autre est un processus qui demande
un apport d'énergie c'est la
photosynthèse la photosynthèse demande
que les plantes reçoivent de l'énergie
du soleil
si vous mettez pas la lumière dans le
placard ce que vous y mettez ne pousse
pas donc il faut absolument apporter de
l'énergie pour que la plante fonctionne
et c'est un processus donc qui est un
processus lent le photosynthèse et en
plus ce qui n'est qu'un processus de
contacts ça ne se passe au niveau du sol
ailleurs dans l'atmosphère serna pas
la dissolution dans l'océan c'est un
simple processus de transfert sert quand
la concentration en co2 dans l'air est
supérieure à celle dans l'eau il ya une
partie du co2 qui passe de l'air dans
l'eau j'ai juste un processus
d'équilibrage
c'est pas un processus de réaction
chimique d'accord c'est juste vous avez
deux compartiments c'est un système de
vases communicants et ça passe de l'un
dans l'autre ce qui veut dire que c'est
réversible
ça peut repasser de l'océan dans
l'atmosphère pas de problème tu vois ça
l'a déjà fait dans le passé à cause de
cette caractéristique de très très
grande inertie chimique du co2 quelque
chose qu'il faut que vous ayez en tête
parce que ça va structurer et ce qu'il
vous reste à vivre comme ce qui me reste
à vivre mois soit dit en passant c'est
que à partir du moment où on arrête les
émissions le surplus de co2 qu on a déjà
créé au bout d'un siècle il y en a à peu
près la moitié qui sera toujours au
dessus de nos têtes
donc il sera un peu y en a b c mais il
en restera toujours la moitié au bout
d'un millier d'années il en restera
toujours un pour cent et au bout de dix
mille ans il en restera toujours 10%
je vous le dis autrement à la différence
de tous les jeux vidéo vous adorez en ce
qui concerne le changement climatique a
pas de bouton reset
quand vous perdez la partie vous êtes
perdus c'est fini il ya pas de bouton
reset on peut pas dire qu'un petit gibus
si j'avais su j'aurais pas venu et on va
refaire différemment et par ailleurs à
cause de cette très très grande inertie
du co2 dans l'atmosphère
il faut savoir que quand ma génération
ce qu'elle doit faire
commence à s'agiter ce qu'elle ne fait
pas assez pour faire baisser les
émissions elle travaille pour la vôtre
dit autrement la dérive climatique des
20 prochaines années est totalement
embarqué dans les émissions qui ont déjà
eu lieu celle là on ne peut absolument
plus rien y faire donc l'évolution
climatique des 20 prochaines années est
scellée dans les émissions qui ont déjà
eu lieu donc toute baisse des émissions
qui a qui démarre aujourd'hui ne sert
qu'à la génération qui suit c'est déjà
bien mais voilà
mais ça veut dire que l'on travaille
toujours pour la génération suivante
cette affaire qui est évidemment un
énorme problème dans les systèmes court
termiste que nous avons construit dans
lesquels il y a des choses que vous
adorez comme par exemple les comptes
trimestriels et la cotation en bourse
qui sont des systèmes à raccourcir les
échéances de temps
manière absolument considérable là on
est en train de parler de processus qui
se passe sur des échelles de temps qui
dépassent l'entendement et qui dépasse
sur tout le système politique les
échéances peu électorale que nous avons
mis en place
donc là aussi je vous renvoie aux bonnes
lectures 1re au lycée tocqueville la
démocratie est un système terriblement
court termiste qui est très mal armés
pour faire face à ce genre de défi alors
dans les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre il y en a une partie qui vient de
l'énergie et les émissions venant de
l'énergie augmentent parce que l' usage
de l'énergie augmentent
vous avez ici les énergies qui sont
utilisés par les hommes depuis un siècle
et demi ce qui saute immédiatement aux
yeux normalement quand vous voyez ce
graphique c'est que à l'échelle mondiale
il n'y a jamais eu de super de
substitution entre énergie les énergies
que nous utilisons se sont empilées les
unes sur les autres
toujours ce que vous voyez c'est que le
charbon s'est rajouté à la biomasse le
pétrole s'est rajoutée au charbon le gaz
s'est rajoutée au pétrole etc et les
nouvelles énergies renouvelables qui
nous excite temps en ce moment là éolien
solaire et autres se rajoute au reste
qu'elle ne substitue absolument pas à
l'échelle macroscopique tard ajoute si
je vous demande à votre avis ces
dernières années qu'est ce qui a le plus
augmenté en matière d'approvisionnement
énergétique
je vous fiche mon billet qu'une partie
non négligeable de la salle va me dire
ah quand même sur les années qui
viennent de s'écouler
ce qui a le plus augmenté si les
énergies renouvelables perdu vous avez
ici un graphique qui vous donne la
variation de l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial depuis l'an 2000
mais je vous aurais montré depuis l'an
2010 c'était pareil qui vous montrent
que encore aujourd'hui les énergies qui
en valeur ajoutée en valeur absolue
pardon augmente plus reste des énergies
fossiles
sur les 18 dernières années l'énergie
qui a le plus augmenté
cette charte ont suivi c'est
l'électrification de la chine 1 très
clairement c'est l'électrification de la
chine suivi derrière du gaz tout à fait
faux cils même s'il va devenir vert part
at il suivi derrière du pétrole est ce
que vous voyez c'est que le vent et le
soleil sont loin derrière et en fait si
le journal avait été avait eu une
pagination proportionnel à ce qui se
passe dans le monde
sur les 18 dernières années eh bien pour
un article parlant du solaire il aurait
dû vous en faire 11 parlant du charbon
ce qui n'est pas je crois ce qui l'a
fait petit sujet soit dit en passant en
petite question vous savez que nous
avions des moulins à vent
il ya deux mille ans nous avions des
moulins à eau partout dans l'empiré
romain
donc en fait il ya deux mille ans
l'éolien on connaissait très bien ça
si l'éolien c'est vachement mieux que
les énergies fossiles ce que disent
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de ses
partisans
pourquoi est ce qu'on sait emmerder à
passer de l'éolien aux énergies fossiles
si c'était vachement mieux n'ai pas de
raison de faire ça en fait quand vous
regardez l'histoire vous vous rendez
compte que ce qui s'est passé c'est
l'exact inverse de ce qui est présenté
parfois comme étant l'évidence il ya
quelques siècles nous avions une marine
100% renouvelable vous avez ici un
bateau 100 % renouvelable fait en bois
renouvelables avec des voiles en coton
et en lin renouvelables mus par des
marins ou des galériens parfaitement
renouvelables aussi parfois ayant un
défaut de citron dont il avait le
scorbut renouvelables et on s'est dit
dans quand même pour approvisionner le
supermarché du coin pour pas cher c'est
quand même vachement mieux d'avoir une
marraine fossile donc on va fossilisés
la marine nous l'avions des transports
terrestres parfaitement renouvela donc
voyez ici une charrette en bois
renouvelables dont je triche il doit y
avoir trop fait rire déjà pas
renouvelable mais peu importe avec un
cheval renouvelables mangeant de l'herbe
renouvelables etc
puis on s'est dit non quand même
toujours pour remplir le supermarché du
coin c'est quand même vachement mieux
d'avoir des transports fossiles nous
avions une agriculture renouvelables
avec un tracteur renouvelables
s'appelait un boeufs et des chevaux de
13 pour ça qu'il ya des boucheries
chevalines et mangeant de l'herbe
renouvelables etc
puis on s'est dit non quand même pour
avoir le mcdo pour pas cher que
n'importe quelle autre marque on s'en
fout c'est quand même vachement mieux
d'avoir une agriculture fossiles nous
avions des travaux publics renouvelables
alors c'était un peu loupé pour faire
les voies romaines certes pour faire bon
maintenant pour faire des ronds points
ça c'est quand même vachement important
les ronds points
nous avons des engins fossiles c'est
quand même vachement plus efficace nous
avions de la construction renouvelable
en bon un siècle pour faire notre dame
en version 1
par axelera plus vite aujourd'hui pour
faire des grands cornichons en bas
résille à la défense j'aimerais bien
psychanalyse et l'architecte soit dit en
passant
vous aller beaucoup plus vite que ça
grâce à l'énergie fossile nous avions
une industrie renouvelables vous voyez
avec des moulins à eau renouvelables on
s'est dit non quand même pour faire les
jouets à noël pour pas cher c'est quand
même vachement mieux d'avoir une
industrie fossiles et donc on a
fossilisés l'industrie on avait une des
séchoirs à l'usr renouvelables ça
s'appelait le soleil aujourd'hui nous
avons des séchoirs à lui 0 à gaz
donc ça fait deux siècles que en fait
nous venons de faire l'exact inverse de
ce qui est présenté aujourd'hui comme
une évidence sur le plan économique sur
le plan écologique enfin voila quand
même c'est renouvelable c'est l'avenir
c'est pas cher c'est c
sauf que ça fait des siècles que nous
faisons exactement l'inversé
donc il doit bien y avoir une petite
raison est en fait il ya une raison elle
est physique alors pour comprendre cette
raison physique on va faire un petit
détour par la tour et celle qui est déjà
monté en haut de la tour eiffel à pied
par ascenseur à pied en deux par les
escaliers
une fois qu'il a déjà fait six fois
d'affilée personnes bon alors le petit
calcul que je vais vous montrer c'est si
vous le faites si fois d'affilée pour
qu'on va imaginer que vous montez six
fois d'affilée et ans mademoiselle la
presse un peu moins 80 kg mais c'est pas
grave on calculait comme un bon ordre de
grandeur que vous allez le faire six
fois d'affilée avec un petit sac sur le
dos pour avoir de quoi casse croûte est
quand même ce qui vous fait faire de
1000 mètres de dénivelé dans la journée
quand vous allez faire ça avec vos
jambes et vos jambes vont évidemment
fournir de l'énergie l'énergie qu'elle
fournisse sa sert a hissé votre corps
contre le champ gravitationnel d'accord
c'est à ça que ça sert et bien en
faisant cet exercice normalement vous
fait pas tout les jours vous allez
fournir une énergie mécanique qui est de
l'ordre d'un demi kilo watt heure
c'est-à-dire 1,8 million de joules ça
que vous allez fournir avec vos jambes
en une journée de transpiration si on
imagine que vous faites ça un jour sur
deux donc la fin de l'année vous êtes
super entraînés il paraît qu'il ya des
courses d'ascension comme ça dans les
phares la tourner en principe à quoi bon
bref donc là vous c'est très très
entraînés et bien à la fin d'année vos
jambes auront fourni une énergie
mécanique de l'ordre d'une centaine
innovateur d'accord c'est ça qu'il faut
avoir en tête donc un homme au travail
de force est capable sur l'année en
utilisant les plus puissantes ses
muscles c'est à dire ses jambes de
fournir une centaine qui de
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
si vous prenez mon ouvrier des travaux
publics des temps anciens et que vous
lui faites décaissé quelques tonnes de
terre dans la journée là en l'occurrence
j'ai pris six mètres cubes de terre
c'est-à-dire quinze tonnes comme pas mal
il aura des bonnes ampoulé mal au dos à
la fin de la journée et qui remonte sa
d'un mètre eh bien il est dix fois plus
ridicule comme grimpeur de tour eiffel à
la fin de la journée il a fourni 0,05
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique qui à
la fin de l'année s'il fait ça un jour
sur deux 10 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique alors à ce stade 10 100
kilowatts heure saoudite ait pas grand
chose
alors là où ça va vous dire quelque
chose c'est que si vous faites brûler un
litre d'essence qui vous savez c'est
beaucoup trop cher ce que les gilets
jaunes le dise
et bien si vous faites brûler hier litre
d'essence vous à les libérer
10 kilowatts heure d'énergie thermique
et une fois que ce sera passée dans un
moteur il vous en restera deux à 4
kilowatts heure d'énergie mécanique
c'est à dire que dans 1 litre d'essence
qui coûte le prix scandaleusement cher 2
1 euros quelque chose vous avez la même
capacité à transformer l'environnement
qu'avec 10 à 100 jours de travail de
force d'un être humain un litre
d'essence donc nonobstant le fait que la
france est un pays tout nucléaire
chaque français consomme plusieurs
centaines de litres par an en moyenne de
l'ordre de 6 ans maintenant si on parle
pognon puisqu'ici axa qui vous intéresse
je sais bien si on prends mon ouvrier on
esclaves
mon fournisseur d'énergie mécanique vous
allez voir on va en fait je vais skier
tout ce que je vais vous expliquer c'est
que parler pognon n'a aucun intérêt
justement c'est ça le problème c'est que
c'est une convention extrêmement
réductrice de ce qui se passe dans
l'ombre
si vous payez la personne qui vous
fournit de l'énergie c'est à dire la
transformation du monde au smic
vous allez payer votre kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique entre quelques
centaines et quelques milliers d'euros
alors qu'en face la machine vous fournit
le même service pour un coût marginal de
l'ordre de quelques dizaines de centimes
dit autrement quand vous passez de
l'homme à la machine et c'est pour ça
qu'on a abandonné les énergies
renouvelables c'est exactement pour ça
renouvelables
vous êtes capable de diviser par
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
le coût d'une transformation unitaire de
l'environnement c'est-à-dire le coût du
fait de passer de la laine à un pull
d'une fibre textile un vêtement d'un
minerais métalliques à des pieds de
chaises etc tout ça a été divisée par
quelques centaines à quelques milliers
grâce à l'apparition des machines et de
l'énergie donc je suis en train de vous
dire quelque chose de très simple c'est
que votre pouvoir d'achat et le mien et
celui de tous les français et de tous
les habitants du monde repose
aujourd'hui sur l'énergie c'est ça que
l'énergie nous a ramenés c'est
l'explosion de notre pouvoir d'achat
les gens n'étaient pas plus cons que
nous avant d'avoir découvert les
énergies fossiles à vous savez même
certains qui étaient beaucoup plus
intelligent que n'importe qui pris dans
cette salle mais il n'avait pas
l'énergie fossile à leur disposition
donc ils n'ont pas fait de pouvoir
d'achat pour tous ce qui fait de pouvoir
d'achat pour tous c'est l'énergie
c'est même ça qui a libéré les esclaves
si vous prenez un esclave ce qui
normalement n'est pas une vocation de
jeunesse sauf quelques rares personnes
qui le crie pas sur les toits
vous allez devoir aller chercher cette
personne contre sa volonté ce qui va
vous coûter de l'argent
la nourrir parce que sinon vous perdez
votre actif l'empêcher de vous trucider
comme dans django ce qui va également
vous coûter de l'argent et d'empêcher
tout le camp ou les deux à la fois du
reste comme d'antan coccyx et bien si
vous mettez boutabout tous les coûte que
représente la possession d'un esclave
qui va vous fournir un service vous vous
rendez compte que même ça ça va vous
coûter 10 à 100 fois plus cher que la
machine qui est pas syndiquée à la cgt
et son conducteur parfois mais pas elle
qui travaille h 24 et qui n'a
strictement rien contre sa condition de
machines donc la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes passés de l'homme à la
machine et des énergies renouvelables
qui sont beaucoup moins dense que les
énergies fossiles aux énergies fossiles
c'est parce que ça a permis d'augmenté
indéfiniment notre costume de superman
est aujourd'hui en fait l'énergie
ça représente notre costume de superman
ou d'iron man alors c'est pas un costume
de superman ou d'iron man que vous
enfilez le matin avec la lumière qui
brille au centre mais par contre c'est
ta costume de superman d'iron man qui
est constitué des trains des avions des
machines à laver des laminoirs des
cimenteries des tracteurs des
moissonneuses batteuses
et des machines réfrigérante etc bref de
tout ce parc de machines que nous avons
actuellement dans le monde et qui
travaillent pour nous pendant que nous
on est occupé à se raconter des
histoires dans cette salle on se raconte
des histoires dans cette salle pendant
ce temps là les machines boss et elles
sont en train de vous préparer votre
bouffe
si je regarde la puissance du parc de
machines
aujourd'hui installé dans le monde c'est
à dire la totalité des machines que j'ai
donné plus celle que j'ai pas nommer qui
utilisent leur nourriture bien à elle
qui s'appelle de l'énergie et bien à
tout instant dans le monde
la puissance du parc de machines en
fonctionnement c'est plusieurs centaines
de fois la puissance musculaire de
l'humanité et dans les pays occidentaux
le multiple est plus proche de 1000 donc
ce que je suis en train de vous dire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la production elle
n'est pas faite par des gens elle est
faite par des machines
donc ce qui fera le succès de votre
business plan c'est pas des gens c'est
des machines la raison pour laquelle le
pib français a été transitoirement
supérieure au pib chinois alors que les
chinois ont toujours été
considérablement plus nombreux que les
français c'est parce qu'il fut une
époque dans l'histoire où les français
ont le plus de machines que les chinois
à bas ce qui fait la production je vais
y revenir après c'est les machines alors
ça ça vient un tout petit peu heurté les
cours d'économie vous apprenez ici les
cours d'économie vous apprenez ici sont
notamment basés sur un postulat qui a
été émis à deux siècles par un certain
nombre d'économistes dont monsieur jean
baptiste ce que vous avez ici et ses
économistes ont dit la nature ça vaut
zéro d'accord ce que nous donne la
nature c'est gratuit alors je vais
prendre un exemple tout con il y a dans
l'atmosphère 20% d'oxygène
si je retire les 20% d'oxygène alors
c'est 20% d'oxygène de son dans aucun
compte de résultat d'aucune entreprise
dont vous allez faire le business plan
vous êtes d'accord avec moi je n'ai
jamais vu une ligne de charge avec
l'oxygène dans l'air
je vois si l'un d'entre vous l'a vu il
faut qu'ils arrêtent de fumer mais sinon
non
donc c'est gratuit puisque c'est dans
aucune ligne de charge
sauf que si je retire l'oxygène de l'air
vous pourrez tous il ya plus
d'entreprises et appuie compte de
résultat donc voilà quelque chose qui
est gratuit indispensable et en fait
tout ce que nous avons sur terre et
gratuit est indispensable le système
climatique et gratuit est indispensable
l'existence d' océans est gratuite et
indices mans
et c'est alors on pourrait s'amuser à
regarder combien ça vaut je vais vous
livrer ce petit calcul que je trouve
rigolo
vous avez ici la résidence secondaire de
monsieur thomas pesquet c'est à dire la
station spatiale internationale
alors la station spatiale internationale
vaut 100 milliards de dollars et c'est
un appartement capable d'héberger six
personnes ce qui veut dire que ça vaut
15 milliards de dollars par personne
n'est d'accord
à quoi ça sert la station spatiale
internationale ça sert à créer à un
endroit où ça n'existe pas une pression
d'une atmosphère un air respirable et un
début de cycle de l'eau d'accord ça ne
sert qu'à ça ça sert même pas à faire
pousser une carotte pour faire pousser
une carotte là haut ça sert même pas à
cultiver un champ anglais pour soi voilà
ça sert pas un pêcher un poisson tout ça
n'existe pas ça sert juste à créer une
atmosphère une pression d'une atmosphère
en est respirable est en début de cycle
de l'eau ça ça vaut 15 milliards de
dollars par personne alors je vais vous
dire la planète terre qui nous offre une
atmosphère respirable une pression de
une atmosphère au sol et un cycle de
l'eau et plein d'autres trucs puisque là
on peut pêcher des poissons faire
pousser des carottes et aller se balader
au bord de la plage ça vaut au moins 15
milliards de dollars par personne
d'accord avec moi si vous regardez
quelle est la fraction de la planète que
nous détruisons chaque année pour
alimenter notre système économique c'est
au moins un pour mille c'est à dire que
chaque année disparaissent au moins un
pour mille des stocks de poissons des
stocks de pétrole des stocks de gaz des
stocks de minerai des stocks d'espèces
et c'est donc le comptable passe par là
il dit bah tu détruis à pour 1001 trucs
qui vaut 15 milliards tu vas me passer
une dotation aux amortissements de 15
millions par an par personne
d'accord en face de ça vous avez un pib
qui vaut 15 mille dollars par personne
et par an donc vous voyez je suis en
train de vous expliquer que si je prends
une convention économique pas plus
idiote qu'une autre notre économie est
une machine à perdre a cramé du cash
mais on s'enrichit par le père ont cette
fois ci c'est une machine à cramer du
cash
mille fois plus vite du côté de ce qu'on
perd que du côté de ce qu'on gagne avec
une simple convention économiques
dérivés de ce que coûte la station
spatiale internationale
donc le fait que notre économie
aujourd'hui soit eu un système
profitable pour les hommes c'est une
vision
conventionnelle c'est pas une réalité
c'est la réalité c'est qu'il ya du
confort matériel à court terme mais le
fait que le bilan global de long terme
sont une bonne affaire c'est clairement
conventionnelle cette histoire alors si
je vous le dit autrement on a considéré
que la nature étant gratuite et elle
était donc infinie c'est ce que disait
c'est et donc si elle est affiliée ça
peut pas être inséré facteurs limitants
du système productif donc le système
productif n'a que deux facteurs limitant
donc deux facteurs de production le
travail humain et le capital humain et
ça suffit pour que le supermarché soit
remplie alors la personne qui passe par
là et qui s'intéressent un peu au flux
physiques va vous dire ou pour remplir
le supermarché faute est d'avoir les
ressources qui vont donner les produits
qui seront au supermarché c'est
compliqué de passer chez zara
si lara de vouvant qu'un concept de
vêtements il vaut mieux qu'il vous vend
des vêtements
donc ce vêtement il est fait avec de la
matière cette matière a bien dû être
trouver quelque part ça s'appelle une
ressource
donc c'est soit des fibres végétales
soit un bout de pétrole si jamais vous
avez des fibres synthétiques sur vous
puisque toute personne dans cette salle
qui porte des fibres synthétiques portes
du pétrole et puis il faut avoir une
capacité à transformer ses ressources
c'est le travail et cette capacité à
transformer les ressources elle est
faite pour un tout petit parti les
muscles des hommes et l'essentiel de
cette transformation bien des machines
dans cette affaire le capital est une
simple boucle internes au système
puisque cet immeuble qui est un élément
de capital il a été fait exactement
comme vos chaussettes en transformant
des ressources naturelles pareil quand
même processus physiques là vous
comprenez qu'il ya d'autres facteurs
limitants qui interviennent si je n'ai
pas assez d'énergie pour alimenter mes
machines je vois j'ai beau avoir plein
de gens qui sont d'accord pour se lever
le matin parce que monsieur macron les
en à persuader et plein de banquier très
sympathique pour investir parce que
madame lagarde est en a persuadé si j'ai
pas assez d'énergie pour faire tourner
les machines je n'aurais pas assez de
pib même si j'ai plein d'hommes et plein
de banquiers compatissant et si j'ai pas
assez de ressources à transformer même
motif même punition
et si j'en ai assez c'est quand même
aujourd'hui le premier facteur limitant
de l'activité économique donc je vous
présente donc n'allait pas en cours de
macroéconomie ça sert à rien
voilà le seul modèle macroéconomique que
vous avez besoin d'avoir en tête celui
la marche très très bien il marche très
bien depuis que j'ai commencé à le
regarder
le système le modèle macro est nominé
économique pendant que je vous présente
vous dis que là le pib dans le monde
c'est à dire la valeur économique des
ressources qui ont été transformés ces
salles pib 1 est une fonction quasi
linéaire de la quantité d'énergie que
nous utilisons c'est à dire du parc de
machines en fonctionnement
vous regardez la taille du parc de
machines en fonctionnement ce que
l'énergie vous mesure et vous avez la
production s'est terminée n'ai pas
besoin de vous enquiquiner plus que ça
sauf que ça amène au drame des
négociateurs climat c'est comme
l'essentiel de cette énergie et fossiles
et qu'on va voir dans pas longtemps
qu'on n'est pas près d'en sortir
eh bien vous avez à peu près la même
relation quasi linéaire pib co2 donc la
très très bonne nouvelle que je vous
annonce c'est que pour qu'on s'en sorte
avec le climat il faut que l'essentiel
de vos business plan s'inscrivent dans
le cadre d'une récession
je le répète ou non c'est bon c'est ça
que ça signifie s'en sortir sur le
climat si nous faisons ça on a une toute
petite chance vous allez voir le rythme
de tenir les deux degrés si nous ne
faisons pas ça
nous n'aurons pas les 2 degrés donc nous
aurons une régulation par la catastrophe
qui marche très bien aussi
l'histoire entre donc l'histoire des
19ème et du 20ème siècle elle est très
très simple nous avons sous terre des
combustibles fossiles qui sont gratuits
comme toutes les ressources naturelles
donc le pétrole est aussi gratuite le
vent personne n'a rien payé dans cette
salle pour que le pétrole se forment ces
combustibles fossiles fournissent un
approvisionnement énergétique
c'est-à-dire une capacité à transformer
n'importe quoi d'autre tout aussi
gratuit soit dit en passant est donc ça
ça nous a permis de faire les objets qui
nous entourent le système socio
économique sur lequel est basée la
productivité du travail qui n'est rien
d'autre que d'avoir adjoint des machines
aux hommes
augmenter la productivité du travail
c'est pas que vous êtes transformés en
shiva avec 253 bras et 96 jambes c'est
juste que on vous a adjoint des machines
qui travaillent pour vous mais on a
laissé juste les hommes au dénominateur
donc c'est juste un artefact normatif de
fait que la productivité du travail
augmente votre puissance musculaire elle
n'a pas augmenté
et on a l'habitude de comptabiliser
économiquement ce qu'on fait en appelant
sa pib alors il ya plein de facteurs
limitants qui s'applique j'ai dit tout à
l'heure la y en a deux sur lesquels j'ai
un tout petit peu détaillé le premier
c'est le changement climatique qui est
un facteur limitant
s'il y en a trop ça va empêcher le
système de fonctionner il ya un deuxième
facteur limitant qui lui est déjà à
l'oeuvre en europe qui est un goulet
d'étranglement sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique fossile c'est à dire que les
énergies fossiles comme elles ne sont
pas éternels et bien on peut pas
éternellement en extraire de plus en
plus et donc il ya un moment où on
commence à avoir des problèmes
si je suis un peu plus précis si vous
tapez dans un stock de départ qui est
donnée une fois pour toutes
donc ce qui est le cas du skate k du
pétrole du gaz du charbon vous êtes
d'accord avec moi que l'on ne peut pas
avoir une extraction indéfiniment
croissante en provenance de ce stock des
mathématiques vous l'interdisent on peut
même pas avoir une extraction
indéfiniment constante en provenance de
ce stock les mathématiques vous
interdisent aussi ça en fait les
mathématiques ou force à avoir une
extraction qui ressemblera à ça c'est à
dire que sa part de zéro si vous avez
suffisamment loin dans le passé ce qui
peut assez facilement se vérifier ça
finira à zéro si vous aller assez loin
dans le futur ce qui peut aussi assez
facilement se montrer au pire d'un 4
milliards d'années quand les hommes
disparaîtront sous la géante rouge
solaire n'est sûr qu'ils auraient pu
d'extraction de pétrole mais bien avant
ça s'arrêtera et entre les deux vous
aurez un maximum absolu qui s'appelle le
pic et se pique il aura lieu pour le
pétrole mais il aura aussi lieu pour le
minerai de cuivre pour teintait le texte
n pardon le tantale le bord le banat
diom le chrome etc
dès que vous sortez quelque chose de la
croûte terrestre le stock de départ est
donné une fois pour toutes vous auriez
un maximum annuel à l'extraction de
cette ressource en décembre 2018 l'
agence internationale de l'énergie a
sorti un rapport que vous pouvez voir
ici sur lequel il est explicitement
écrit et alors la presse française n'a à
peu près pas parler que le maximum pour
l'extraction du pétrole dits
conventionnels c'est à dire ce qui n'est
pas le celle aux états unis et ce qui
n'est pas les sables bitumineux du
canada est passé en 2008 qui en avait
entendu parler dans la salle on voit
trois l'a48 d'accord
je peux vous dire que c'est
considérablement plus structurant pour
le régime des retraites que les
négociations qui sont actuellement en
cours dont on nous rebat les oreilles
soir et matin parce que ça sa structure
la quantité totale de pognon qui va se
partager
et si la quantité totale de pognon qui à
se partager baisse
on peut faire toutes les danses de la
pluie qu'on veut sur les promesses de
l'augmentation du point d'indicé de chez
pas quoi il y en aura juste pas plus
d'accord donc la pagination du journal
aurait dû être inversée on aurait dû
vous rabattre les oreilles soir et matin
avec ça et vous parlez de temps en temps
de ce qu'il ya en négociation sur les
retraites mais je vous assure que ça va
pas être le problème
enfin vos retraites même la mienne votre
problème ça va pas du tout être la
nature des négociations qui en ce moment
un médecin si on regarde tout ce qu'on
peut sortir de terre sous forme de
liquide donc y compris le chevreuil le
etc
je vous la fait courte mais bonne en
gros le maximum total c'est pas 2008
c'est dans les années 2020 et le pétrole
est la plus limitantes des énergies au
sein de toutes les énergies parce
qu'elles commandent les transports
est ce que vous voyez ici c'est la
variation depuis 1960 soit 65 de la
quantité de pétrole qu'on sort de terre
c'est bien la quantité pas le prix que
vous avez ici en rouge et du pib par
personne en bleu est ce que vous voyez
c'est que depuis les chocs pétroliers où
on a rendu le pétrole le on s'est limité
au maximum sur ce qu'on pouvait faire
avec le pétrole c'est qu'on a on a
vraiment été grattée de l'efficacité
partout et bien les deux sont
parfaitement a servi et quand il ya un
décalage temporel c'est le pétrole qui
varient avant le pib
donc c'est pas parce qu'il ya de la
croissance qui vient de mars on achète
plus de pétrole
c'est parce que on a plus de pétrole il
ya plus de machines qui peuvent échanger
entre elles et à ce moment là production
augmente et inversement dans l'autre
sens et il n'y a pas de lien entre
volume et prix en ce qui concerne le
pétrole donc ça c'est un deuxième truc
qu'on vous apprend peut-être ici et qui
est totalement faux en ce qui concerne
le pétrole est en fait qui est
totalement faux en ce qui concerne
énormément de choses vous avez ici un
graphique dans lequel j'ai mis en
abscisse la quantité de pétrole qu'on
achète sur le marché dans l'année que la
quantité produite en gros et là vous
avez le prix par baril si vous avez une
élasticité prix volume telle qu'on la
prend
parfois en cours les points devraient
être organisées comme ça c'est à dire
que moins il y en a plus c'est cher et
plus il y en a moins c'est cher c'est le
fameux truc quand vous apprend à l'école
là ce que vous voyez ces excès il n'y a
rien qui ressemble à ça en ce qui
concerne le pétrole vous avez une espèce
de plasma getty est en fait si vous
regardez l'histoire vous vous rendez
compte que pendant cinquante ans vous
avez un volume qui varient
considérablement avec un prix qui reste
constant
ensuite vous avez un volume qui ne varie
quasiment pas avec un prix qui fait
n'importe quoi et re belote et rebelote
vous ne verrez pas arriver la
raréfaction du pétrole par le fait que
le prix s'envolent indéfiniment c'est
pas comme ça qu'on va le voir en idées
vous verrez arriver la raréfaction du
pétrole par le fait que le capex par
baril extrait par jour lui augmente
indéfiniment
ah oui mais pas le prix à cause du pic
de production du conventionnel en 2008
l'europe a vu son approvisionnement
pétrolier contraint à partir de 2006 je
vais accélérer un peu là parce que je
vote le temps l'heure tourne donc en
europe l'approvisionnement pétrolier
aujourd'hui est contraint
l'approvisionnement en gaz en europe a
commencé à baisser à partir de 2005
parce que la mer du nord qui nous
fournit l'essentiel de notre gaz a
commencé à baisser à partir de 2005
c'est le pic de production qui est
passée le charbon baisse en europe
depuis des décennies parce que ça fait
deux siècles comptable dans nos stocks
de charbon ça date de bien avant qu'on
commence à s'occuper du climat et donc
si vous rajoutez charbon pétrole et gaz
qui font 75 % de l'approvisionnement
énergétique européen tousart a commencé
à baisser depuis 2006 vous y rajoutez le
nucléaire combès volontairement pour de
mauvaises raisons sur moi mais on fait
quand même c'est pas les énergies
renouvelables que vous avez ici les
nouvelles là qui vont compenser la
baisse de manière extrêmement
significative vous voyez sur ce
graphique vous avez trois temps sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne en europe un premier temps
jusqu'à la fin des trente glorieuses au
moment des chocs pétroliers qui signifie
l'arrêt de la hausse et c'est à partir
de ce moment là que les économistes
commencent à se dire ah tiens où est
passée la productivité la productivité
est passé dans le fait que l'énergie
c'est à dire que la quantité de machines
en service par personnes s'arrêtent de
croître c'est juste l'axé passé
ensuite vous avez 40 ans pendant lequel
ses constants or l'économie commence à
patiner un taux d'endettement augmente
la productivité augmente lui aussi vite
qu'avant chômage commencent à apparaître
etc
et puis vous avez un deuxième coup de
tabac dans la sphère c'est le début de
la baisse de l'approvisionnement par
personne et à ce moment là ça commence
vraiment à déconner dans les grandes
largeurs l'endettement explose le
chômage commence à augmenter de manière
significative
vous vous mettez à avoir de l'inflation
d'actifs partout quand vous commencez à
faire du quantitative easing etc
vous voyez apparaître les taux négatifs
donc là le système est vraiment en train
de commencer a déraillé et savait que le
début et ça n'est que le début
et si vous regardez la variation du pib
par personne sur ces trois temps et bien
vous voyez avant au moment où le
l'énergie par personne a augmenté
rapidement on était à 4% par personne et
par an au moment où l'énergie s'arrête
de croître
on n'est plus qu'à 2 et là dedans il ya
déjà un début d'inflation des actifs et
depuis 2006
on est quasiment à zéro et vous demander
à ce moment aux anglais si ça leur plaît
les anglais goodies non en ce qui
concerne le climat
l'essentiel de ce que je vais vous
raconter tient dans cette carte vous
avez ici les une représentation des éco
systèmes installés en europe avant le
début du changement climatique donc on
va dire en milieu du xxème siècle ce que
vous voyez c'est que à ce moment là les
écosystèmes si on les supprime pas pour
faire des tas de trucs un futile comme
des chants et des routes et des trucs
essentiels comme le campus de l'essec et
bien vous avez essentiellement des
forêts
donc ça veut dire que partout en europe
il pleut suffisamment pour que poussent
des grosses espèces végétales qui sont
les arbres voilà à quoi ressemble
l'europe il ya vingt mille ans alors il
ya vingt mille ans évidemment les sexes
n'existe pas
les hommes sont un peu moins nombreux
nous sommes au coeur de la dernière ère
glaciaire temps qu'il fait beaucoup plus
froid qu'aujourd'hui le climat a varié
spontanément n'y a pas que les hommes
qui font varier le climat nous on fait
varier très vite trop vite mais il varie
plus lentement ont naturellement et vous
voyez que la géographie européenne ne
ressemble à rien de ce à quoi il
ressemble aujourd'hui d'abord il n'ya
pas d'erasmus chez les suédois donc
oublier la [ __ ]
parce que la scandinavie est recouverte
de trois kilomètres de glace
exactement comme le cas d'adhara
tabernacle soit dit en passant comme
cette glace a été constituée en prenant
l'eau là où elle est disponible
c'est-à-dire dans l'océan et que l'oni
le fond de l'océan on n'a pas changé
parce que les tourbains endroits le
niveau de l'océan a baissé de 120 m donc
vos grands parents n'auraient pas perdu
leurs économies dans l'eurotunnel
c'était pas la peine de faire eurotunnel
vous voyez il n'y a pas de manche la
branche a disparu des écossais ne nous
enquiquine pas aussi nations les
irlandais toujours malheureusement c'est
que c'est non il fait beaucoup plus
froid dont beaucoup plus sec et vous
n'avez pas de forêt quasiment pas de
forêts en europe tout ce que vous avez
c'est de la steppe et de la toundra et
dans ce genre d'écosystèmes vous arrivez
à faire vivre sans bilbon sommes en
france donc la population française de
l'époque c'est un petit arrondissement
parisien
quand la terre est passé de la dernière
ère glaciaire à l'ère préindustrielle et
que les écosystèmes en europe sont
passés de ça à ça manifestement la
température s'est réchauffée et bien le
réchauffement planétaire qui correspond
à cette transition
ces 5 degrés en dix mille ans avant de
détailler très rapidement les
conséquences du changement climatique
retenez juste cette phrase de conclusion
5 degrés en un siècle
c'est la guerre partout c'est très
exactement ça 5 degrés en un siècle
c'est la guerre partout c'est à dire que
la déstabilisation des conditions
environnementales ira à une vitesse
telle au surplus dans un monde qui sont
la deuxième partie du siècle commencera
à être en contraction énergétique subi
c'est-à-dire en défaut de moyens de
réaction face à l'adversité
c'est absolument évident
que la façon dont le système à réagir
c'est en créant des conflits et des
tensions absolument partout quelques
exemples ici vous avez le nombre de
jours qui seront les taux c'est à dire
qu'il sera physiquement impossible de
survivre en 2100 avec une élévation de
température qui serait de 4 degrés la
raison pour laquelle s'est concentrée
près de l'équateur c'est qu'il fera
tellement shoah dans ces endroits là
avec une humilité tellement importante
que vous ne pourrez plus transpiré pour
évacuer votre chaleur et donc vous
mourrez d'hyperthermie trop chaud
d'accord eh bien vous voyez qu'il ya des
endroits dans lesquels vous aurez ça
quasiment toute l'année
l'a350 pour parents ça c'est un
graphique qui vient du dernier rapport
du giec qui s'appelle changement
climatique et terre et qui vous dit qu'à
partir de 3 degré d'élévation de
température il ya une insécurité
alimentaire généralisée sur la planète
or la sécurité alimentaire généralisée
c'est la violence généralisée
c'est une constante dans l'histoire des
hommes le groenland a commencé à fondre
et l'antarctique de l'ouest est en
risque de déstabilisation si on dépasse
la trajectoire des deux degrés
l'antarctique de l'ouest finira
probablement par se désagréger ça plus
ça ça va être neuf mètres dos en plus
dans l'océan en l'espace de quelques
siècles
alors ces quelques siècles met le doigt
sur la gâchette s'est tout de suite
voilà je vous détaille pas les
conclusions je vais juste finir avec le
dilemme du cou qui s'offre à nous ici
vous avez une deuxième droite importante
qui vous donne la réponse en température
du système climatique en fonction de la
quantité totale de co2 qu'on mettra dans
l'atmosphère entre l'ère préindustrielle
et 2100 à fin 2010 8
on avait mis dans l'atmosphère 2200
milliards de tonnes de co2 ce qui nous
garantit une élévation de température de
25 degrés donc en fait les 1,5 degré
dont on parle parfois dans les
engagements politiques dans les discours
d'entreprise etc en disant on va faire
ce qu'il faut pour que en fait on peut
plus rien faire pour ça c'est terminé
d'accord ils sont déjà perdus si on veut
les deux degrés il faut qu'on limite les
émissions cumulées d'ici à 2100 à 3000
milliards de tonnes de co2 dont 2200
déjà été émise 2250 pour être précis ce
qui veut dire que d'ici à 2100 on a
encore le droit d'émettre le tiers
de ce qu'on a déjà émis dans le passé
pas plus alors qu'on va être en moyenne
trois fois plus nombreux sur terre
donc ça veut dire que l'empreinte
carbone de chaque personne dans cette
salle doit être le dixième de celles de
vos grands parents
sur l'ensemble de votre durée de vie
c'est ça les deux degrés ça veut dire
également que d'ici à 2050 il faut
diviser les émissions planétaires par
trois ce qui est une autre manière de
dire qu'elles doivent baisser de 4% par
an donc tout business plan qui n'est pas
compatible avec une baisse de 4% par an
des émissions planétaires n'est pas
recevable au titre de la préservation du
climat
je peux vous dire que c'est à peu près
n'importe quel business plan que vous
ferez à peu près n'importe lequel
donc la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes c'est que aujourd'hui nous avons
navigué entre deux risques
il ya un homme s'appelle mark carney qui
a publié sa il ya enfin qui a parlé de
ces risques il ya maintenant trois ans
juste avant la coupe 21 ou bien on ne se
soucie pas à court terme de maîtriser
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
disant tant qu'on peut on en profite et
à ce moment nous aurons de façon
irrémédiable à cause de l'inertie du
système et on peut plus éviter des
risques physiques qui risque de porter
atteinte à l'espérance de vie d'une
large partie de la population sur terre
ou alors on se sert très très vite la
ceinture en disant on va comme ça éviter
les risques majeurs en ce qui concerne
le climat est à ce moment en gros on
provoque une récession mondiale de
grande ampleur c'est l'un ou chez
l'autre
c'est pas fromage et dessert
malheureusement
dans cette affaire les entreprises elles
ont évidemment un rôle à jouer et je
vais finir avec ça vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui il ya énormément il ya
peut-être quelques personnes dans cette
salle qui ont signé le manifeste
étudiants pour un réveil écologique même
si je veux dire des choses très
désagréable y en a moins dans les écoles
de commerce que dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs je me demande bien pourquoi
et au titre de ce manifeste
il ya un fait sur le site du manifeste
et un petit d'identiques greenwashing
que je vous conseille d'aller lire il
est rigolo
aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas une
entreprise qui vous dis pas le
développement durable c'est vachement
important etc
je vais faire tout ce que je peux pour
être 2° machin patates et chiffons alors
moi je dis ok ces gens là pour me
raconter exactement ce qu'ils veulent je
ne crois pas une seconde
ce qu'il me raconte tant qu'ils n'ont
pas fait a minima la liste que je vais
vous découvrez maintenant vous avez tous
entendu changement climatique
mille fois vous l'avez peut-être entendu
mille fois je pense que pour autant il
ya très peu de gens dans cette salle qui
sont capables de me décrire dans le
détail de quoi il retourne exactement
c'est à dire quels sont les ordres de
grandeur les constantes de temps les
causes les processus enjeux etc
je pense pas or vous ne pouvez pas
correctement traité un problème tant que
vous n'êtes pas correctement capable de
le décrire c'est à dire que tant que
vous ne savez pas décrire correctement
un problème ce que vous croyez être une
solution en fait ça sera tiré au hasard
et quand vous tirez au hasard la
probabilité que vous atteignez votre
cible est extrêmement faible
aujourd'hui c'est ce qui est très
exactement en train de se passer dans le
monde économique et dans le monde
politique c'est à dire que les gens qui
doivent prendre des décisions à défaut
de compréhension du problème à traiter
qui est majeur notamment pour des
raisons démagogiques mais pas que et
donc ils tirent au hasard et mon avis
personnel c'est que pour commencer à
comprendre de quoi il retourne en ce qui
concerne les histoires que j'ai très
brièvement abordé ce soir il faut en
prendre pour 10 à 30 heures
ensuite vous n'êtes comme le carbone
n'est pas dans les euros vous n'êtes pas
capable de comprendre à quelle distance
vous êtes du problème tant que vous
n'avez pas une comptabilité qui est
adapté aux problèmes à traiter votre
comptabilité monétaire ne vous dit
strictement rien sur là où vous en êtes
en ce qui concerne la question climat
rien donc tant qu'une entreprise n'a pas
fait une comptabilité carbone détaillé
qui permettent à chaque cadre dans
l'entreprise
donc vous quand vous serez plus grand
d'être capable de confronter la décision
enfin la caractéristique monétaire est
la caractéristique carbone de la
décision à prendre
vous n'êtes pas outillés pour naviguer
dans ce monde là et ça concerne
quasiment aucune entreprise en france il
y en a quasiment aucune qui est à ce
niveau là ensuite je ne connais pas une
entreprise à quelques rares exceptions
près qui est aujourd'hui une stratégie
long terme
enfin déjà compter sur une stratégie
dans tnt book qui est une stratégie long
terme qui soit compatible avec une
baisse de 4% par an des émissions ce qui
veut dire que ça contre un très
rapidement les moyens de transport
disponibles les moyens de production
disponibles le pouvoir d'achat des
consommateurs
les implantations géographiques y reste
accessible et c'est évidemment il faut
regarder ça sur l'ensemble de la chaîne
de valeur on connaît quasiment pas une
qui ait fait ça quand les entreprises
disent qu'elles vont prendre des
objectifs en général elles les prennent
en par unité produite
donc elles disent je vais faire baisser
et typiquement air france il ya quelques
jours je vais faire baisser mes
émissions par passager kilomètre mais
enfin dans le même temps ils veulent que
leurs passagers kilomètres augmentent
plus vite que la baisse unitaire des
émissions j'appelle pas ça à traiter le
problème
si vous dites je vais boire moins par
heure mais beaucoup plus souvent il
n'est pas complètement exclu que votre
foi se porte plus mal quand même
et enfin il faut que le processus soit
piloté donc si vous n'avez pas ces
affaires-là pour lesquelles vous avez un
membre du comex qui y passent au moins
25 % de son temps c'est que le truc il
est traité par dessus la jambe
dernier point dans toutes les
entreprises il ya des parts variables
il y en a un certain nombre si cette
affaire-là n'est pas dans les parts
variables c'est que le sujet n'est pas
sérieux donc là je vous donne
à tout petit sous ensemble parce qu'il
ya beaucoup plus que ça évidemment
affaire qui est indispensable pour
qu'une entreprise puisse commencer à
prétendre qu'elle fait des choses
sérieuses sur la question tant qu'elle
n'a pas fait tout ça ça ne m'intéresse
moi même pas d'écouteurs façon
m'intéresse de travailler avec elle
c'est mon métier mais je n'accorde à peu
près aucun crédit à ces déclarations
publiques sur ses brevets de vertus
autoproclamé voilà et je suis au bout de
mon temps je m'arrête
merci
merci beaucoup monsieur jean marchand
plus jeune est devenue devenue ce soir